hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on new world again and
today I just wanted to share with you a
quick little video of what's going on
they just released a dev diary talking
about some of the combat some of the PvP
and a lot of stuff we're gonna be
experiencing with the new world so let's
talk about that today as always like the
beef you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new and with that let's get started with
today's video so the topic like I said
is going to be on Kombat PvP magic all
that sorts of jazz right not exactly
what some of the PvP elements are like
we've talked about and other videos like
opting in and opting up but more of what
that combat is and how we're going to be
functioning with it and action in this
game is more of a real time combat more
of an action RPG more than just an MMO
lunges dodges swings combos etc are all
going to be with all the weapons that's
the hugest part of new world they also
mentioned as well that there's going to
be the weaponary
Master System every weapon has a skill
tree with new bonuses and skills some of
these compare really well with Gears so
if you're a big guy that likes axes
might want to equip heavy armor and just
our tanking or if you like guns you
might want to hop on some clothing to
maneuver faster pretty much with this
mmo's do not have classes they have
pretty much just weapons so these
weapons the more you use them the more
you level them up and the more you level
them up you're in progression points and
you can use those progression points
within that weapon to make your own sort
of skill tree so in a sense it is a
class game but it's more of weapon
classes not necessarily a whole class in
general like magic-user healer etc like
in other traditional MMO so as I said to
increase the rank of these weapons you
have to use these weapons a lot more and
you can make a total changes to your
entire weapon and play style just by
doing this for example for example one
of the weapons is the hatchet and you
can choose to have up close combat with
it or just throw from a distance using
range combat
for example the shield even just has
straight-up attacking or you can apply
buffs to said shield for your teammates
even magic is potential in this as well
one of the things with this is that
magic can be used by anybody it's not
just a set class like other MMOs have if
you put a lot of appoints into
intelligence and focus you can actually
be better at magic than others and once
the same thing there's going to be skill
trees and progression systems with that
so you'll be able to do a lot more magic
damage than a lot of other players in
the game giant fireball storms ice
storms giant anything like all that type
of stuff maybe even a traumatic for
talking Skyrim here but
stuff like that loads of different
spells and then of course they stated it
the best way to experience this pvps
through the faction war battles and the
territory Wars which can encourage PvP
as well and that's pretty much the gist
I want two guys just to give you the
quick rundown of some of the combat
that's going on with the game especially
the fact that there's the weapon mastery
system like I stated with all these
skill trees I think it's gonna be a
whole lot of fun I am super excited to
see what kind of weapons and class
setups are gonna be doing obviously you
have stuff like the gun so maybe there's
gonna be a probably a multi shot kind of
skill tree section maybe it's just one
shot but maybe more powerful I'd love to
see what other things like that let me
know let me know in the comments below
what you guys think of some of the class
stuff might be or if you're an alpha
player maybe you are able to disclose
that maybe maybe I don't know either way
let me know in the comments below if you
guys think about this stuff with that
take care guys grandpa Griz today and
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]